pour parler de cette idée de mettre en
commun les dettes de l'union européenne
nous sommes avec françois asselineau
président de l'union populaire
républicaine
bonjour françois asselineau bonsoir
plutôt merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france alors la création de corona
bronze
si c'est accepté ce serait une première
dans l'union européenne
oui bien entendu ce sera une première
mais ça n'aura pas le nul c'est à dire
que le sujet qui est actuellement évoqué
parle de prêts de la banque européenne
d'investissement des jeux comme ça
la question essentielle c'est de savoir
si notamment l'allemagne seraient prêtes
à mutualiser les dettes prises par les
pays du sud
et ceci jusqu'à la fin des temps et
madame merkel a toujours répondu non non
et non non de son vivant donc en fait on
parle pour ne rien dire
et en fait ce qui se cache derrière
cette opération en tout cas c'est mon
analyse et s'éteint et les européistes
comme macron sont absolument aux abois
parce que la construction européenne est
en train de s'effondrer sous nos yeux
sous nos yeux on apprend ce soir est un
que l'allemagne a décidé de ne plus
appliquer la directive des travailleurs
détachés d'ailleurs notez bien qu'il ya
deux choses terribles mais vraiment
terrible que révèle cette affaire du
coronavirus au delà des milliers de
morts qui arrive les deux choses
terribles pour les européistes c'est que
on s'aperçoit que l'idéologie européiste
favorise la libre circulation des virus
et sabote toute capacité à lutter contre
je m'explique pendant des semaines on
nous a expliqué qu'on ne pouvait pas
mettre de frontière que c'était
contraire aux principes du libre échange
et tatati et tatata et en même temps
découvrait que notre système de santé et
dans un étang voix de tiers-mondisation
pas seulement en france mais aussi en
italie
au point même que désormais l'italie et
bientôt la france sont obligés d'appeler
à l'aide
la russie la chine même cuba et le
venezuela parce que ça fait des
décennies ou en tout cas des années que
l'on est en train de détruire l'hôpital
public sur les pressions de bruxelles
on va revenir ensemble sur sur ces
corona bond vous le lisiez vous parliez
de l'exemple de l'allemagne
tout à l'heure qui a qui a toujours
refusé mais elle a renoncé à la sacro
sainte règle des 3% récemment c'est bien
la preuve que peut être tout est
possible siméon mais rien n'est possible
écoutez vous avez vu ce qui vient de se
passer quand même
il n'y a eu aucune solidarité européenne
la république tchèque à relais de l'aide
chinoise qui étaient transférés à
l'italie elle les a volés pour son
propre compte
tous les pays de l'union européenne ont
fermé leurs frontières ils ont interdit
de servir aux petits copains le matériel
dont ils avaient besoin
vous avez même vu que la pologne a
interdit le survol des avions russes qui
veut apporter de l'aide humanitaire à
l'italie aujourd'hui regardez ce qui se
passe en italie l'italie teulier
beaucoup plus proche dans tous les
domaines de la russie de la chine de
cuba que de la pologne où des de
l'allemagne donc en réalité c'est ce que
je disais à l'instant ce qui est en
train d'apparaître c'est que la
construction reprenne est en train de
s'effondrer
absolument sous nos yeux dans yeux la
deuxième chose que je voulais dire tout
à leur honneur est interrompue c'est que
regarder les décisions prises par la
commission européenne
c'est absolument fascinant la solution
les seules solutions qu'apporte la
commission européenne et européiste
c'est de dire aux états et bien écoutez
n'appliquer plus les traités et
n'appliquaient plus que je vous
demandais depuis des années de faire
c'est à dire que maintenant il n'y a
plus de règles budgétaires n'y a plus
tout est en train de partir en
quenouille
ce qui prouve bien que lorsqu'ils les
choses sont graves tout le monde
reconnaît que l'idéologie doit céder le
pas devant la réalité
françois asselineau plusieurs
personnalités politiques à travers alors
hop déplorer jusqu'ici le manque de
solidarité européenne la création de
c'est corona bon ben ça ne sais pas
peut-être une première étape de cette
solidarité européenne justement vous y
tenez beaucoup aimé que répondre je vous
dis que ça n'aura pas lieu puisque il ne
regardait les allemands en sont à
refuser la libre circulation des
travailleurs
ils ont refusé de laisser partir du
matériel dont ils avaient besoin
les polonais ont refusé le survol
d'avions russes donc vous imaginez que
ce sont des détails mais ce qu'un par
rapport à cette création film pénale que
consisterait qui consisterait à
mutualiser l'ensemble des dettes
figurez vous que les allemands ne
veulent pas et ça vous ne pourrez pas
changer de peuple allemand
mais il ya un pas que les armes hors
d'eux il ya les finlandais ya les
néerlandais etc
ils ne veulent pas comptabilisé il sans
précédent s est ce que la situation ne
pourrait pas changer justement dans
cette situation de crise sans précédent
est ce que justement les pays comme
l'allemagne la finlande que vous citez
elle ne pourrait pas revoir leur copie
cc c'est vraiment vous pensez
rédhibitoire écoutez ça fait des
décennies que ça dure et ça ne nuit pas
dans ce n'est pas au moment où tout
s'effondre que l'on va voir ça vous
savez apprendre le chinois que j'aime
bien inciter qu'ils disent et d'en lire
toute sa vie que le croire à ses rêves
mais en fait ce n'est pas un rêve c'est
véritablement un cauchemar parce que la
réalité de la situation et c'est ce que
qu'on veut ce que constatent les
français c'est qu'en fait on a des
gouvernements qui ont été complètement
privés de du sens des responsabilités
ce qui apparaît de façon flagrante c'est
l'irresponsabilité la désorganisation
l'incompétence extravagante du
gouvernement français et c'est aussi une
certaine forme de déliquescence de
l'état et d'anarchie de l'état parce que
on ne le souligne pas suffisamment mais
les français odin au quotidien il
constate que macro est complètement à
l'ouest à un jour il dit qu'il faut que
tout le monde reste chez soi le
lendemain il va se balader comme ça sans
masquer les mains nues dans des hôpitaux
ambiance comparant à clemenceau dans les
tranchées 1914 il est un peu un peu
dérangé mais puisque vous les français
c'est qu'il n'y a plus
pilote qui à la barre et donc on assiste
à une espèce de prise du pouvoir un peu
partout vous avez des mairies qui décide
d'appliquer le par le protocole du
professeur raoul c'est le cas à nice
vous avez des chu qui décide de prendre
contact avec lui à celle de monsieur
raoul pour impliquer le protocole vous
avez madame pécresse qui décide de son
côté d'acheter des masques
vous avez des entreprises qui décident
de faire des masses donc il décide de
fabriquer des respirateurs l'état étant
est en voie d année sens parce qu'en
fait à la tête de l'état nous avons
macron une camarilla qui ont son temps
de khimki ont qui n'ont plus le les
pouvoirs et qui sont absolument de coupé
des réalités les ressasser fait valoir
de dépendre de l'union européenne qui a
progressivement affaibli même détruit
l'idée même du sens de l'état
merci beaucoup françois asselineau
d'avoir été avec nous ce soir sur rtl
france rappelle que vous êtes le
président de l'union populaire
républicaine merci beaucoup pour
rappeler que c'est aujourd'hui le 13e
anniversaire de notre mouvement
politique que j'ai créée justement le 25
mars 2007 c'est à dire le jour du ce
était le 50e anniversaire du traité de
rome c'est aujourd'hui le 63e
anniversaire du traité de rome
nous avons beaucoup progressé depuis là
on a dépassé les trente neuf mille
adhérents et ce que je voudrais dire à
vos interlocuteurs offert aux auditeurs
avant de terminer c'est quand même un
message d'espoir c'est que on voit bien
qu'on est en train d'arriver c'est la
fin d'un monde
l'union européenne s'est terminée tout
est en train de s'effondrer
il faut maintenant que les français se
rassemblent comme nous l'avons fait le
31 janvier dernier
qu'ils se rassemblent de droite et de
gauche pour reprendre le pouvoir
redonner un france sa souveraineté son
indépendance sa liberté et ses capacités
de se défendre y compris de protéger les
plus faibles en notamment en
réhabilitant un véritable service public
hospitalier merci beaucoup françois
asselineau encore une fois d'avoir été
avec nous ce soir sur arte france